it off to mateo mateo do you want to
take it over
yeah thank you very much paige
so today i'll be presenting with my
friends and colleagues
so dave mihaila and
jun fabio and anteo and
basically our objective is to give you
an overview of the
ecosystem and the tools and libraries
that we've been building around jax
and to try to give you a feel and an
understanding of why we
we as a group and as a company are quite
excited about jax
and also hopefully help answer some
questions from you about
uh maybe what are your doubts what are
your concerns and
whether or not jax could be also useful
for your own research and for your own
projects
so let me start maybe with a with a very
brief introduction to
to jax and to at a very
like bird's eye why it might be an
exciting framework to work in and
build machine learning projects and
research on
so at its core uh many of you will be
already familiar but uh let me just
repeat really the fundamentals at its
core jax is a python library that is
designed
for high performance numerical computing
and
it among it's like key ingredients it
basically supports three
main areas one is differentiation so
forward and reverse mode automatic
differentiation of
arbitrary numerical functions and here
we have a whole lot of like
jack's primitives like grad hessian jack
jacobian forward jacob
rev that all allow you to basically
implement
and exploit the automatic
differentiation capabilities of jax
the second broad family of primitives
that jax
offers to its users are related to
vectorization and automatic
vectorization
so in a lot of machine learning we rely
on a single instruction multiple data
style of programming where we typically
want to
apply the same type of transformations
to a whole batch of
identical data so we might for instance
be computing a loss
over a big batch of the input and output
samples
and the jax basically makes life a lot
easier to researchers and
and practitioner of machine learning by
exposing some very neat and simple
abstraction to simplifying single
instruction multiple data programming
these are mostly v-map and p-map and
we're gonna hear some
some examples today of how these can can
really make the difference in writing
clean
but expressive code and finally the
third
big area inside jax is jit compilation
so just in time compilation
and basically jax is built on top of xla
and uses xla to just in time compile
your code
and make both faster your cpu code if
you're running a cpu
but also give you transfer parent gpu or
cloud cpu and acceleration
the the important feature of jax like if
you are to
basically take away just one message
from what is jax is that
all these these these functions and
these abstractions are implemented as
composable program transformation
so what what does this actually mean
let's let's give a very very concrete
simple example and consider a numerical
function that just squares an input
and sums to the second argument of that
same function
you could brighten python this way and x
and y could be for instance numpy arrays
the value of this function is of course
evaluated like any python function you
just call the function pass some inputs
and and the the first input will be
squared and sum to the second one
what would computing a gradient look
like with jax well
the neat thing of jax is that the
gradient of this function is comp is
also a function
so you just call jax.grad on a function
and you get back something that is still
a python object it's still a python
function
but that if you call now computes the
derivative
of the original function in a very neat
and transparent way
and importantly these uh this
transformation is composable so you
could for instance compute the second
order gradient
by calling grad of grad of the original
function and this again gives you just
the python function
but then if you pass x and y gives you
the second order gradient in
those two values of x and y
similarly you can mix and match this
with other program transformations like
compilation so if you just
compute if you just call jit of grad of
grad of the original function this gives
you a compiled second order gradient
function
that again will you can just call as any
other python function but the first time
you call it will trace the code and
compile it using xla
and then the second time you're all
following times you will call the same
function
it will execute a pre-compiled xla code
and therefore be much faster
and of course this doesn't stop here all
the jack's primitives are neatly
composable so you could for instance
batching
your your function you just write it as
if you were just dealing with single
examples
but if you remap that function again you
get a function that now
expects a batch of inputs and computes
the same function of the on the entire
batch and finally if you want to then
execute these batched compile second
order gradient calculation
in parallel and multiple multiple
accelerators for instance this could be
multiple gpus you just need to chain one
more now you p-map a v-mapped legit
grand of a grad of a function
and again this is just a python function
that you can call on your inputs
and i hope this gives you a flavor of
how composable gradient
program transformations enable jax to
expose a very
thin set of primitives that are easy to
understand
but that you can then combine in very
rich and very powerful
programs that can support quite quite
powerful use cases
and before i i leave to my colleagues to
delve into
into more details i just want to
conclude with
a couple of final remarks on why jax is
so convenient
and i think there are a few things to
remember one is of course this
composable
nature of all its uh abstractions but
it's
also good to remember that all of the
numerical functions are written in
with a with a syntax that is fully
consistent with numpy so it's literally
you're just literally just writing numpy
code but then you can transform it using
these program
transformations this means that jax can
be quite familiar even when starting
because
python and numpy are widely used and
also in a couple of of points i want to
highlight is one day is not a vertically
integrated framework
like like many other ml frameworks
it's really focused on getting this core
bit of numerical computing right
and then it's it still provides you with
a very rich ecosystem built around it
and a community around it that can
give you the um you can make other like
other things and classical things like
building neural networks easy for you
and this is what david is going to be uh
talking about
just now
hi um yeah thanks a lot mateo that's a
great overview um so my name is david
i'm a research engineer at deepmind
and i'm here today to talk a little bit
about our deep mindjacks ecosystem which
is
essentially a collection of libraries
that we've been developing together over
the past 18 months or so now that build
on top of jacks as matteo just been
explaining
um and sort of added additional
functionalities with functionality
rather than specific machine learning
research
thanks likely too
um so why an ecosystem so deepmind
researchers have had a lot of
great initial success using jax so this
is normally a nervous hosted event
many of the papers that we're presenting
in europe this year um use jacks under
the hood for
to produce the results um as engineers
and researchers at deepmind we're
constantly asking the question
how can we continue to support and
accelerate this great work and this
early success that we've seen
um there are a few considerations that
go into this the first is mateo which is
saying is the jax is not a vertically
integrated machine learning framework
this is the strength it does one thing
very it does a core set of things very
very well
and what we want to do is um what we
want to do is build on top of this and
continue to build our own libraries on
top to meet the specific machine
learning research and our particular
needs
um whatever we build needs to support
our rapidly evolving requirements you
know for instance a specific focus on
reinforcement learning among other
things
and where possible we want to strive for
consistency and compatibility with
frameworks and tools we've released in
the past for instance the compatible of
tensorflow
things like sonos and truffle um
the solution we've arrived that is is an
ecosystem which is
basically a collection of libraries of
reusable and unopinionated
jax components um each library is
intended to do
one specific thing well and importantly
supports incremental buy-in
so for instance we're going to show you
libraries for neural networks libraries
for optimization for reinforcement
learning
from day one we've made sure to develop
these in a way such that you can pick
and choose the pieces you want
without being locked into any decisions
about other libraries or other tools
from within the same library
and of course where possible open
sourcing everything to enable research
sharing
and reproducibility of our results that
we build on top of the jacks ecosystem
thanks a lot i'm quickly going to go
over three examples of libraries we've
built although there's others and i
encourage you all to check them out now
for more details
we we posted a blog recently on the
deepmind.com website that goes through
this in more detail
um so haiku is our jax library for
neural networks so as mateo is
highlighting much of the strength of jax
comes from essentially this functional
programming paradigm
whereby we have stateless functions and
we can compose function transforms so
it's just a gravity map of
whatever returns a function that
function can be statelessly applied to
to whatever to some numpy array or some
jackson umpi array
um often some abstractions that are
common to machine learning things like
neural network trainable parameters and
state uh fit the object oriented
paradigm potentially better or at least
is how people are used to thinking about
this
so higher kind of tries to bridge the
gap between the object-oriented world
and the functional world of jax
it essentially provides tools by which
you can take um stateful objects such as
neural networks
and convert these into initialization
and application functions
that can then be used directly in jacks
our researchers have had great success
on trivially porting previous tensorflow
results
such as um the the alphas here for
instance into
into jacks and it's a widely used and
mature framework both within deepmind
but um
more widely within google and the public
community as well
next slide
opdax so optax is for optimization so
much like neural networks it often makes
sense to think about neural networks in
an object-oriented
paradigm as having state um optdx is
essentially a gradient processing
optimization library that's core
provides sort of a zoo of common
optimizers that people
know and love things like sgd art and
momentum whatever it may be
and these are importantly these are
defined as this chain operation
of simple optics primitives so sort of
fundamental gradient processing
primitives
they're common to many of the optimizers
and many other things as well
so optics provides these for simple
out-of-the-box implementations changing
these components to give us build
optimizers
and gives the user a lot of
functionality to do this themselves
in addition it provides a lot of useful
utilities that allow the trivial
application
of gradient-based updates to neural
network parameters
i'm not just haiku parameters for
instance using out of the jacks neural
network library
but sort of true to the spirit of
incremental buy-in and
cross-compatibility
um all or at least most of the popular
jackson neural network libraries
you may be familiar with should be
compatible with objects anything that
represents the parameters as a tree of
numpy arrays essentially again widely
used within deepmind with a growing user
base outside
next slide please so
as you probably know deepmind cares
quite a lot about reinforcement learning
i guess one of the one of the
complexities of reinforcement learning
is it's very easy to get things wrong
for instance if you place a stop
gradient in the wrong place which can be
very simple to do
the entire experiment is going to fall
apart um
the idea of relax is essentially to
provide a library of
trusted battle tested reinforcement
learning components so not even
algorithms with sub-components of
algorithms for instance on the
right-hand side
you can see how a q-learning primitive
and a square loss primitive
can be combined to define a simple loss
function that you might want to use
and essentially this provides a
substrate by which our researchers can
use components they trust and have
algorithms that they trust
in addition to quickly contributing
their own ideas back
to be shared amongst the broader
community um a lot of the emphasis we
face on this library has been on
readability
so for instance what does this mean now
we use unicode everywhere so if you have
a look at our doctrines you know we're
not just
scared to reproduce our doctrines to
look like textbook examples but also not
being afraid to repeat ourselves as well
if we want people who land on a function
for td error
to see where the td error is not need to
chase this down three or four different
functions
next slide so i don't have time today to
go over all the libraries that we've
released as part of our ecosystem but
there are others
for instance the giraffe library for
graph neural networks which we released
last week
as well as our chex library for testing
and reliability
here are some links here i encourage you
to check them out in addition to this
world view that we're telling you today
about an ecosystem
i suppose there's an additional shell
around the outside of this which are
frameworks that are then built on top of
these libraries
um some examples from deepmind are
jacksline and acne for supervised
learning in rl i encourage you to check
these out
and in addition to the work from
deepmind we've been talking about today
there's a lot of really great work in
building being built on top of the jacks
ecosystem
both being google and in the public more
generally
so for the rest of this presentation i'm
going to hand over people who are going
to talk more about their sort of
research results have been based on jax
and jack's ecosystem are starting with
michaela who's going to talk about
gans and generative models
um thanks abel so i hope everyone can
hear me
and i'm super excited to talk uh today
about what i think makes jax amazing for
generative models and specifically gans
next slide please um and the reason i
chose gans is because they're a bit
different than the standard view that we
might have of
other generative models of this paradigm
of one model one loss
in the gen case we have two models we
have the players the
generator which is producing data and
the discriminator which learns to
distinguish between this generated data
and the real data and the goal of the
discriminator
is to be really good at distinguishing
between these two and the goal of the
generator
is to basically be to
fool this discriminator into thinking
that the data that it generates
is real and
um the the way to to do this is either
via a zero-sum game or via other
types of losses they don't need to be
necessarily connected as long as the
underlying principle
is this we have one player that learns
to distinguish and one player that
learns to
to full and hence the name adversarial
next slide please
now if we want to implement this in in
jacks one thing that we notice straight
off the bat is that
when when you uh implement again you
might want to do multiple discriminator
updates for each generator update
um or vice versa often more of the
discriminator
and this is super trivial in jax you
just have to write the python for loop
for each of the players we all know how
to do that
and inside this uh python for loop for
each of the players you decide to update
the parameters of that
player and the really neat things about
this
that also mateo highlighted earlier is
that
we now can get gradient functions so not
gradient values but we can ask jax well
jax can i please have
the gradient function which is the
gradient of the discriminator loss with
respect to the discriminate parameters
and then i can evaluate that function
at the current values of both of the
discriminator parameter generator
parameter
and what other data batch i might have
and so on and crucially here there's no
need for any stop gradient on the
parameters of the generator even though
the value of that
loss will depend on these parameters
because we just ask
jax for the gradient with respect to the
first argument which is the
discriminator parameter so this is very
nice
very easy to reason about and almost
like a pseudo code if i
if you ask me to write a pseudo again
algorithm pseudocode it will look very
similar to this and i think this is
really
really
nice now once we have the gradients we
can pass them to
an optimizer like an octagon optimizer
that they've talked about
getting an update getting our new
discriminator parameters and then doing
exactly the same thing for the generator
this
time only that we use a different loss
the generator loss
and we get a new gradient function the
generator loss function
gradient with respect to the generator
parameters
so this is all uh very neat next slide
please
but one thing that i want to highlight
here
we now have direct access to gradients
so for example if i want to see how the
norm of the gradient at different layers
looks like i can easily
do that i can just add one or two lines
of numpy
um code that i'm familiar with and i can
get
i can get those statistics and i think
this is very useful
in terms of allowing us researchers to
build intuition about what our models
are doing in a very simple way
next slide please something else that i
think
is maybe specific to gans that can
that jax highlights very nicely is
it gives you more control and it makes
you think about the kind of decisions
that you're trying to make
so one type of decision for example
is well when i update the discriminator
what should i do about the generator
state and what i mean by state is not
the generator
parameters but for example let's say the
generator batch norm statistics do
or do i or do i not want to update the
statistics
and let's leave aside for now whether
you actually want to do this or not in
gans
the point here is that when you
implement uh
ants in checks it makes it forces you to
think about this and it forces you to
make the right decision so
briefly looking at um at this
quick implementation that i made up the
discriminator loss we see that we have a
four pass through the generator
this returns us a new generator state
and now when i return from this
discriminator loss i can say well
i want to use this new generator state
in conjunction with the new
discriminator state or
next slide please i can just decide to
ignore that and return the state of the
generator that was given to me
very very easy again i have to think
what i want and
getting to what i want is just a matter
of changing a few lines of code here too
instead of digging somewhere deep for
something that i might not have access
to
next slide please and last but not least
i think i i just want to say this
one more time of this functional
approach making making code very
close to math especially in generative
modeling when
we often have a lot of distributions
gradients of things that depend on
distributions
makes it much more easy to to reason
about
and i'm just going to highlight two
things that mateo talked about earlier
which is being able to vectorize
functions
and computing jacobians so if i want to
compute um
let's say gradients with respect to some
parameters
of an expectation of a distribution that
depends on these parameters this is not
revealed we can use the score function
estimator
but that has higher variance and if we
can for some distributions we can use
their parameterization trick
so this is just a trick that allows us
to rewrite that expectation with respect
to another distribution that doesn't
depend on these parameters and push the
parameters inside
now even with this new form now we see
that we still have an expectation so we
have to compute some functions
over multiple samples from this
expectation what we can do
is we can expect the user to just always
pass us in vectorize functions which can
be
okay if it's only neural networks but
sometimes it can be something else we
don't only have to compute gradients
with respect to neural network functions
or we can do it for them and jax really
allows us to do that
by just saying well i'm gonna vectorize
the function for you you can pass in
anything that you want and i
specifically find this very very useful
for tests
because even though we might use neural
networks in our
um in our experiments often we want to
test for a very
complicated nonlinear function and we
don't want to spend the time vectorizing
all of our
uh our functions in our tests and again
if i don't want to compute a gradient
and i want to compute a jacobian it's
just a matter of changing a few
characters and i get
uh get what i want so i think this is
really really
um convenient and very easy to reason
about
and that's it for me and i'm going to
give it up to june who's going to talk
about
meta gradients
thanks um hi everyone i'm jun i'm a
research scientist at deepmind and i'm
going to briefly talk about how
i use jacks for my recent work
next slide please so
in this work on discovering
reinforcement learning algorithms we
try to meta learn a reinforcement
learning update rule
from a distribution of agents and
environments like this figure
but there were several technical
challenges because of the unique
problem set up over here thanks
so first we wanted to simulate many
independent learning agents where each
agent is interacting with its own set of
environments
but this is already quite unusual
because normally in reinforcement
learning we
just consider one learning agent but
here we wanted to simulate
multiple lifetimes of agents
simultaneously
next place and at the same time we
wanted to apply
the same update rule which is the meta
learner to
all learning agents in a completely
synchronized way
next please and also we wanted to
calculate meta gradient over
this asian update procedure which
requires
calculating the second order gradient
and finally if you we wanted to
massively
scale up this approach by increasing the
number of learning agents
without introducing much extra
computational cost
so these were quite challenging so to
address these
challenges we um
we used jacks and jacks actually allowed
us to easily handle all these challenges
in the next slide we i'm going to
briefly describe
how we implemented this system using
jets
and at the beginning we first
implemented every environment
in jax so that we can apply pre-map and
pmf later
and as you can see from this figure we
implemented
a single update rule and single asian
and single jacks environment interaction
which was quite simple and
if you go to the next slide um we and
then we added a feedback
to implement multiple jacks environments
for one learning agent and in the next
slide we added
another vmap at the outer scope to
implement multiple learning agents like
this figure
where each agent still interacts with
its own set of environments
and finally we added pmap to
implement multiple copies of the same
computation graph and then distribute
this
across multiple tpu cores like this
figure
with a shared update guru so in this
figure each tpu core
essentially has its own set of agents
and its own set of environments but they
all
share the same update rule and they all
calculate the meta gradient
and in a completely synchronized way and
then perform meta
update if you go to the next slide
and this is the pseudo code of our
algorithm so here
the top part implements the agent update
and the bottom part implements the meta
gradient calculation
and the yellow part is the free maps and
pmap that i
mentioned in the previous slides so if
we just remove these remaps and p-maps
then
it essentially becomes the single asian
optical environment interaction but by
just adding a few
b maps and peanuts like this figure
we can easily convert the the simplest
single interaction implementation to the
massively parallel
system that i showed in the previous
slide so in the actual experiment we
used the 16 core
ppu and using this tpu we could simulate
1 000 parallel learning agents and
60 000 parallel environments with
one global shared update rule and we
were
able to process more than 3 million
stats per second using
16 core gpu so
next slide please to just summarize we
had several
interesting challenges because of this
unusual
problem setup but by using jackson tpu
we were actually able to handle all
these challenges
quite easily without putting much
engineering effort
which was quite nice for us and also we
got
quite interesting results out of this
project so if you are interested in this
project please check out the paper and
also come by the postal session tomorrow
yeah that's all i have thanks i'm going
to hand over
fabio and d
uh hi everyone so i'm theo i'm a
research
scientist at dmind and i'm going to
present
uh some work we're doing on search and
model bazaar with fabio
um next okay so here we're shifting
gears a little bit so so far we have
looked at applications
of jacks which uh crucially leverages
gradient computation capabilities
uh and you may ask you know is this the
main use of jax is this gradient
uh kind of base computation the main
thing that we care about
so here we showcase another application
where jax enables fast research
iteration
that uses gradient but it's not the core
of the compute and it's
basically multi-colored research in a
model-based r setting
as seen in alpha zero and mu zero so we
are training
rl agents um which uh
plan effectively using an internal mode
of the world create the form of a plan
which is a sequence of action that they
optimize over
and then both use that plan to act in
the real world as well as to update
uh policy priorities that they use to
help to guide the plan
and there are challenges in doing so um
the first is that in a typical
kind of neuroline neural network guided
research you have a tight integration of
the control logic
in your network machinery and this is
actually quite tricky to debug
um there's challenges around scalability
and parallelism because
uh research is inherently a sequential
algorithm five you will
mention more on this later um and as
typical for model-based rl setups there
is a lot of issues around the data
pipelines a lot of
not so much issues as much as design
choices user replay
the share of synthetic data versus real
data how to use data for policy learning
versus model learning
and so on and so you need a framework
which enables you to
quickly test loads of different ideas
and that kind of setup next time
so next yeah so and next again thank you
um so sorry just one one before just a
picture with one
so um in the last few years we've seen
kind of an explosion
of uh a space which finds itself at the
intersection of
search based algorithm which evaluates a
different type of solution
using kind of more discrete type of
reasoning along with
uh neural networks uh so this has been
found in work
uh applied to games such as go or atari
or puzzle games like soccer band as well
as robotics
chemical design robotics and so on
next slide uh and the particular
algorithm that we investigate and
replicate is mu0 which is a
an extension of alpha zero which learns
the model of environment
it's a paper from from last year uh
which obtains
a state of the art results on the verity
of games such as chess shogi go
or atari and again uh has a as a learned
neural network model of the environment
uh next slide so i'm going to give a
very quick introduction of neural
network guided mcts as
it is done in u0 to give some kind of
context around
the issues um so each mcts consists of
several simulations that happen one
after the other
and each simulation consists of three
steps the first
is you traverse uh the tree you have a
you already have a given tree and you're
going to traverse the tree from the root
to a leaf node
using a chosen heuristic and alpha or
mu0 the the heuristic is called puct
and it basically picks node with the
highest score where the score combines
two factor which is a policy prior which
is kind of a
gut feeling of what is the next best
action um action values which are
derived from the
the the tree computation and an
exploration bonus which is derived from
visit council often you've been in a
particular node of the truth
so you keep going down next up next
you keep going down the tree until you
reach a leaf and eventually you reach a
leaf node
and then you add a node to the tree next
so this is called the expansion and this
is the case where you're actually called
on your network because you need to
compute the state transition from the
leaf node to the new leaf node
uh you need to compute the value for
that state and the policy prior for that
state and all of these
consistent calling different neural
networks and eventually you
cache of that competition put it in the
tree and you follow by the backwards
step which to propagate all that
information
from the new leaf node to all the
ancestors into
so this is basically how your network
mcgs works
and next i'll let fabio explain the
issues around implementing
mcts in jax
yeah so hi i'm fabio i'm a research
engineer at dmine
so um so why is
implementing mcts like efficiently uh
like a challenging task
well in in the in the use case like we
have in mind
like it is hard because uh
you know some of us researchers don't
really want to
use c plus class day to day and would
rather use like higher level
languages such as python but
uh sticking with plain python performing
you know i'm cts in batch
can be quite slow um you know making
like our research space slower and
furthermore you know
as you mentioned like vanilla mcds is
essentially a sequential algorithm
which puts even further constraints on
how much we can analyze computation
there is of course work in the space but
um
[Music]
let's stick with you know like the
simplest possible scenario
so one possible approach to tackle all
of the above is to
rely on just in time compilation to
somehow try to bridge the gap between
interpreted
and compiled languages and this is very
well aligned with the programming the
programming paradigm in jax
the next slide so off the bat like if
you decide to stick with the
with jax like we like we did um there
are some you know expected advantages or
disadvantages we can
foresee in particular what we expect is
that uh
you know once we manage to jit
computation we're just going to be
quite performant at least compared to
plain python
something is really relevant for us
especially in rel is to saving costs
moving data
in and out of accelerators which would
happen if you
uh broke out to a search engine class
classroom cpu
uh this in turn allows to uh if you can
you know uh
jit search you can jit the whole uh
acting and the whole learning of our
legends which is really
relevant for performance um
furthermore you know we said that you
know if you can
stick to something that looks a lot like
numpy it's going to be easier to reason
and write and modify search components
um also you can build on top of the
jack's primitives that michaela and
others discussed today to
write your code for a single uh example
and then use for example demon for
vectorization
um furthermore there is this huge
potential of being differentiable all
the way through
next one on the flip side
this is going to be very likely less
efficient
if you are not touching for example if
you want to deploy a trained
rl agent on a single environment um
and also if you are giving up some of
the compute
and memory uh of your accelerators for
search you're gonna have you know a bit
less for plain inference
um and this is gonna have a further
impact on how
deep you can go with your search because
your search depth will be limited by the
accelerator
memory uh furthermore if you're running
all the searches
in parallel the your performance will be
constrained by the slowest instance of
your search
i want to conclude by just showing a
couple of codes deep but
this is very high level but i think it
will kind of uh
nicely reflect what we discussed so far
so uh
this is like an implementation of the
search method
over on our mcds
jax class as you can see um
it is very nice and easy to isolate like
the three main components
of the algorithm which is the simulate
expand and
and and backward function that you can
easily play with
as long as you know they are a nice
legitimate uh function
um i'm also i also want to highlight
that so the the control flow must be
expressed
using uh like the jax lux uh library
for example uh this won't be like a
plane python for loop but it's going to
be a four eye loop
and furthermore if you want to j you
need to make sure to
have like a fixed uh shape in place so
you need to pre-allocate your
data structure will contain all your
search statistics
next one is an example of the expansion
function
uh where everything that is to do with
neural networks can be nicely wrapped
into the single
function call of the recurrent function
as it is in
museum and this again makes it very easy
to break down and focus
only on the few bits you want to do
research on
and now we can move on to questions and
debate can we just ask questions
okay so uh so the most obvious questions
a question i guess is
how does jax compare to pre-existing or
established languages like pytorch or
tensorflow
so what would be the optimal scenario
for jax versus pytorch for example
what benefits would i have if i chose
jax over
of a pi torch
so we uh uh that's an excellent question
um and i i think that part of it would
would certainly
be flavored by um by a personal
perspective but we also have members of
the jacks core team here today
um and i i think that they would also
they that they would be they should have
first
dibs on answering um
matt jj skye do
you have an answer
i can say uh some things at a high level
i guess
um we think pie torch is really great
and tensorflow is really great too a lot
of people are really happy with those
things
and uh you know we don't want to cast uh
you know
you know sort of frame things in in like
a zero-sum way i think there's things
that that
um pytorch does that that are you know
better than what jax does and they're
things that
jax does better i'm more familiar with
the jack side so you know i can say
some things about um what we are trying
to do with it and ways in which those
things might help you um so i think you
know as folks talked about in the in
these talks
um you know jax makes a bet on uh
functional programming
that means that um you know to the user
things and you know maybe being closer
to math
and that's nice um but also it means
that jax can provide some capabilities
uh that work really well around like you
know automatic batching like vmap that
sort of thing
uh you know fancy autodiff um
we got you know we started building
jacks because we worked in
automatic differentiation and so i think
jack still has a lot of cool features
like
forward mode uh and reverse mode they're
composable the way it interacts with
vmap to be able to compute
jacobians and hessians really fast it
has some experimental features about
exponentially faster very high order
auditive so you want to take like 100th
order taylor expansions
it's quite good at that um you know
these are
these are things that are like afforded
by in in part
sort of betting on uh functional
programming um
and so you get sort of these
transformations so i say jax is about
the transformations you know
maybe maybe first and foremost um maybe
you know
another thing to say is that it's very
compiler oriented
i think um mentioned
that she likes being able to dig into um
uh you know the guts of an optimizer and
say
there's not going to be an optimizer
kernel like an atom update op
that's in c plus it's all sort of in
user level python
and that's because uh you know
jax is sort of designed around uh being
compiler oriented
um and that also like means that you can
you can do some things uh
some things well like stage out entire
parts of your computation
we had a you know entry at you know this
is kind of the extreme end not
necessarily what you see um
yourself uh every day but jax had some
ml perf entries that set
uh world records for training uh some
neural networks extremely quickly
like uh uh
english german uh neural machine
translation uh
training in like 16 seconds um that's
sort of like the extreme end
of being uh but it comes out of being
sort of compiler oriented like jax is
based around being able to like stage
out you you giving you the control to
stage out parts of your program
from python hand them off to this like
xla super optimizing compiler that can
project things onto
not just your you know gpu your single
card
or you know your hpu's but also like
entire tpu supercomputers um anyway so
i'd say like at a high level
uh you know the bet around compilers you
know things around functional
programming and just
being focused on providing many
transformations uh
uh and even allowing people experts to
sort of extend
the system of transformations i think
those are things that sort of set jacks
apart um from how other systems have
worked before
whether that is actually useful to you
you know it depends maybe
what's most useful to you is having a
ton of example code out there or you
know having a really big community
um or you know some some uh there's some
workloads that might perform better
in other frameworks for example um but
hopefully that gives you some flavor
along with all the other things folks
have talked about here of you know where
uh jax could be useful yeah dagger
maybe i just wanted to add very briefly
before we move to the next question
a couple of things so just one aspect is
that
jax is comparatively very thin is very
focused on doing
a certain range of things and do them
very well
and i think that can be quite appealing
if you really want to dig
into and have like full control about
what what is going on
the fact that you can really delve into
jacks and basically get a good
understanding of how everything is
working because it's
fairly compact and is only doing a
focused
set of things well i think i found that
personally very appealing and it might
be
something that resonates with other
people and
and maybe and the second i just wanted
to again uh
matthew already touched that but this
functional programming style that allows
to basically expose all their primitives
in terms of composable function
of function transformation has been like
incredibly powerful at least
for me i think drew an example to me is
all as
i worked with him on this project has
been one of the
the most eye-opening for me experience
because we literally just wrote
a single agent interacting with a single
environment and just just
dropped in a couple of bmas a couple of
p-maps and suddenly we were running
a massive experiment across multiple
tpus and multiple environments and
multiple agents and
so i i just want to shout out again the
power of composable function
transformations because it's
it's really amazing
can you can you talk about the debugging
experience like what do you get when you
inspect things and and also when when
jit is involved
probably take it yeah um maybe
mike's so the the nice thing of
debugging in jax is that until you
basically turn on jit you are literally
just executing
uh numpy code literally like it just
looks a lot like it and it's
it actually executes a lot like it so
you can literally
pdb into your program and uh step
through it line by line and just
uh check what then the arrays contain
and so on
and then you can basically just turn on
the jit to make it faster
but you can still debug everything in
this kind of
more friendly python lens so i think uh
the debugging experience from that
perspective is quite
quite nice
if i could tack onto that um you know i
think
you know we're always looking for ways
to improve there's ways to you know have
better
um error messages and and you know track
things but
on the on the subject of yeah just being
able to pop into a python debugger
um as long as you're not using jet so
even things like uh
auto diff um or even if you're using
vmap so like
something that uses both of those is the
jack forward function for forward mode
jacobians
and if you actually like have a function
you're taking a
jack forward of and you put a debug
statement in it so you like
jump into a debugger and you start
printing values it'll actually show you
uh both the sort of like primal point at
which you're linearizing
and the entire sort of like basis of
tangent vectors uh sort of all the
things you're pushing forward
together because both vmap and you know
this uh and autodiff
work sort of in pure python i don't
think it's necessarily you know the
first thing
that you think to do but you do have all
your values there you can like poke at
them and look at them
um so hopefully that helps a little bit
on the debugging front
awesome so uh
latest question then and uh i don't see
any hands raised but if if folks want to
raise hands instead of
asking questions in the chat we can we
can also do that
um so next question from sure hill um is
there a tf data for jax planned by
either the jax team or the deepmind
team oh and uh and uh sorry apologies
for that byron
um byron it seems like you have your
hand raised
uh and are waiting to speak is that
correct
yeah but you can address the the data
one first
sorry the question is is there plans for
our tf data for jax
yes okay well one possible answer to
that question is that
actually many people do use tf data
with jack because you can just kind of
go through numpy arrays as the common
interchange there so there's like
no fancy integration needed
you can really just use these like two
libraries like any other libraries
um so yeah for that reason um and of
course this applies to
like other data loaders as well or your
own custom data loaders
so we don't have any immediate plans on
the jax team to like create our own data
loading library we think many
other groups and teams have done a great
job of this and we don't know if we can
do better
um but yeah i'm interested if there's
any
particular use cases or like features
that aren't well served by the
existing frameworks for data loading
awesome thank you skye and byron um go
for it
cool so first of all um excuse me i want
to
you know thank both the jacks team and
and the deep team because i've been i've
been using
sort of haiku to reimplement some things
um in arlax
in in the last several months i've
really uh enjoyed it like i think
uh matteo said like just the the
functional
uh format of it i find it really
exciting you know one thing that i don't
think anyone mentioned but i found it
really nice
is serialization of model primers is
super super super easy
right like if you just have your params
out you just save off your brand you
blow them back in you're done there's
nothing you have to worry about with
like fancy loaders or anything like that
so i
really like that capability as well for
checkpoints it's really nice
um but my one question i have is again
having worked on this
uh can you guys just speak to like what
um the model is for contributing back to
these projects
um for instance like i noticed you don't
have bi-directional rnn support so i had
to roll my own so what is
in haiku what is what is the process for
contributing that
so maybe i can take the questions for
the
jax ecosystem libraries uh maybe someone
for the jax team can can see more about
uh contributing to jack's score itself
um we we are definitely open to
contributions so we have already taken
quite a few contributions both in in
arlax and
uh and optics for instance uh so i think
that
the the main uh the main message there
is
open an issue in in on github and let's
let's have a conversation there
um i i guess uh it's it's
it's hard to say without knowing the
details uh we we try to
um we have an explicit aim to keep each
library quite focused and and and
similarly to how jax core does one thing
and does it well similarly in our
ecosystem libraries
we try to have you know optics focused
very clearly on authorization haiku very
clearly on neural networks libraries
reinforcement learning very
relaxed very clearly it's only
enforcement learning so there might be
cases where maybe
uh there might be valuable code that
doesn't fit quite exactly one of the
ecosystem libraries in which case might
be
um we might have to make a call in sense
of whether or not it fits the
scope of each library but definitely i
think opening an issue on github would
be a nice way of starting a conversation
excellent now is there anything that you
wanted to add or skye or
tom
we like you know we love open source
contributions so yeah come over to our
good oven and try to make them
uh uh yeah plus one everything
mateo said we actually just had some uh
someone added like windows building
support i think and that was incredible
that was like a issue
number that we had in like the single
digits and some open source contributor
just uh
just contributed it uh so that was
fantastic so yeah
um come to our issue tracker we're often
like overloaded and like time limited
and stuff so
if we don't respond it's not lack of
interest it's just because we're uh
scrambling with other things
um uh but yeah uh we love we love seeing
people
uh start discussions and make
contributions
cool excellent
it looks uh next up is
it looks like horse
all right yeah so i i guess i kind of
wanted to ask more about the debugging
issue or like the debugging topic so
uh like so i i get how the
like like in general like with eager
mode tracks it's easy to debug because
you can just use all your regular tools
but in the presence of transformations
that aren't uh like grit
uh it doesn't still remain easy to debug
uh like i guess what happens if you have
like a
print statement and then you like call
grad or vmap and on it
uh like yeah i guess you can talk about
that
that's a great question i that sort of
was getting at um but maybe it was
sort of hard to explain in words without
you know showing the the code but
um you know we uh uh
jax works by tracing mechanism and that
means that it's sort of propagating
um extra values uh inside your your
python code and so if you print out
a you know if you have a function and
you print out an intermediate variable
in it
and you call grad of that function
you'll see something print out
and jax will sort of like show you the
information that it has
going on under the hood so uh you know
you can use
uh pdb to debug things you end up
looking a little bit
you know behind the scenes like under
the covers of what jax is doing so
you know in the grad case for example
you'll see uh
some you know string that prints out
when you print a value that shows sort
of the
primal value at which you're linearizing
your function and then something
um depending on if you're using forward
motor or reverse mode
uh possibly about the the tangent value
um
that's been in the weeds but i guess
like you know we a lot of jax you know
stays in python jit stages things out
but
um for the things that stay in python uh
you know we try to
make the debugging experience as as
reasonable as possible so vmap as well
as another example you can actually if
you print out the value of a
an intermediate thing in a vmapped
function then it'll actually show you
sort of the value it's keeping behind
the scenes that has that full batch
dimension
um even though like your code thinks
it's operating on single examples
if you print a value jacks will say like
actually i'm hiding a whole batch of
examples behind the scenes here
um but you know all that said those are
just you know ways in which
we've tried to make the python debugging
experience work i'm sure there's lots of
ways that it could be improved still
uh as well excellent
thank you matt and thanks everybody for
for the questions these are great
um i think the next one um is from robin
thanks um does it make sense to mix in a
bit of jacks if you have an existing pie
torch application or does it
really make more sense to just always
completely do one or the other
i think it depends uh you know on just a
lot of situation specific details and
what kind of mixture
you're talking about but i'm i think
actually there's a lot of potential for
interesting ways to
compose things one you know small
example is just being able to hand off
gpu backed arrays efficiently between
the two without copies and without much
overhead
that might be a nice feature if you
actually want to write some parts of
your program
in pie charts you have a function that's
backed by like pie torch operations you
part of it it's backed by jack's
operations um so
i think both pie church and jack's
implement the deal pack standard for
uh sort of exchanging uh memory like
this and
i think there's still some like caveats
like um
there might be like a gpu
synchronization incurred uh or something
like this but
other than sort of you know engineering
uh details that
folks are still working on um you know i
think there's ways that we can make
these things super compatible and that
way users just win
right uh you know there's no reason to
lock people in um
if you have reason to build stuff
together i don't know exactly what those
reasons are or can't think of a
situation necessarily
off the top of my head but we want to
make it so that you can
um you know compose these things and
you're not you're not limited in that
way
maybe i would just add that this is this
kind of potential integrations might
also be held by the fact that jax is
quite focused and quite lenient it's not
like a huge vertically integrated
framework where if you buy into
one aspect of jax you need to buy in
everything else in a specific neural
network library and so on so
being quite lenient might open up being
quite lean might actually make this kind
of integrations
easier although it's hard of course to
discuss without specific details
sky actually in your demo yesterday did
you
was part of the hugging face demo like
loading values from
like pie torch checkpoints or something
[Music]
yeah the bert fine-tuning demo involved
basically downloading from the hugging
face
burt checkpoint checkpoint in pi torch
and then loading it
um into jax but i think that probably
went through numpy arrays because it's
like downloaded on on the host rather
than like through deal pack
perfect so we have a
horse did you have another question or
is your hand still raised
no more questions for me no worries
are there any questions on the chat that
we didn't
get a chance to answer it it looks like
julian
um julian answered ulcers question about
performance um
avitalin and david shared greatly
or james shared great links um
robot has his hand raised now excellent
robert
hi um i had one question just regarding
the the future
of jax and what we can expect
essentially from both the
the deepmind internal packages as well
as the core team
awesome i guess um i can speak to the
demand part
so like in terms of our libraries i
think this model of
having low-level libraries of components
with incremental buy-in has been a real
win for us
i think one of the one of the natures of
research is that it's broad and
unpredictable and moves very quickly
i think often um when we try to go the
other way and sort of
plan in advance you know what what what
we think we need to build in time in
terms of like a
you know press play and run framework um
by the time we've gotten there sort of
the the field has moved on
i think by having these these frameworks
components i mean you know perhaps an
individual component someone contributes
um is not as relevant as it was in the
past but it doesn't sort of affect your
ability to sort of build others or
contribute or expand or whatever it may
be
so certainly this idea of trying to sort
of identify the core features
that are required in our research
contributed back users as a substrate of
sharing research throughout the
organization and to the broader
community as well
and adding more libraries and building
libraries on top of libraries i think
this is this is working really well for
us and something that
at least in the short to medium term we
intend to continue
maybe someone from the jax team can
answer the question in regard to jack
score
yeah i can say something but someone
else from
jack's core interrupted me if they have
a like really good answer i never quite
know you know
um you know answer a question like that
other than to say that like
uh the folks who are working on jax uh
myself included
like we love this project we're like
pouring so much of ourselves into it
and so you know that to me that's sort
of sort of like as much of a guarantee
of uh of you know it's not going away
um as you can get just because you know
we're personally very invested
um i guess the jax team has grown and so
you know
and it's working well things like places
like d-mind and google brain
and uh research more broadly so um
you know i don't think anyone wants to
like uh uh
i think everyone is is uh the best days
of jack's are ahead i guess what i'm
saying
jax is growing uh the folks working on
it are very passionate
uh as you've seen and so you know i
wouldn't worry at all about
um jack's going away or something like
that
awesome and we are we are at
time but we might have time for one more
question um
and it looks like robin had his hand
raised
oh yeah this looks amazing i was
wondering uh what do you think are the
stumbling blocks that new people to jax
often hit upon like are there certain
things that are
more that are often confusing for people
or cause issues
when they're just getting started we
have a great link for that
there's something called the jacks
the sharp bits um
collab on the docks and then i'll i'll
i'll link that
in the chat
in addition i guess i'll add one from
the d mine side i think sort of you know
as like
one of the strengths obviously your
jacks is this um this bet on functional
programming and sort of you're raising
everything into a functional paradigm
where things are stateless and you don't
need to worry about side effects
um i guess as normal like i guess we
decided to sort of you know
diverge from that slightly with some of
our libraries such as haku and the
reason was you know we had other
considerations we needed to balance we
had so many users that are already using
um sonnets as their way of defining and
reasoning about neural networks within
tensorflow
and we really wanted to be able to
maintain that api so certainly there's
some cognitive overhead in
you know sort of writing something that
looks object oriented which is sort of
converted for you into functions and
sometimes it takes some users um
i uses some time to ramp up to but i
mean that was just sort of the
the trade-off that we decided worked
worked for us as an organization
um certainly there are other jacks
neural network libraries that take
different approaches that other people
find work better for them and you know
in the spirit of incremental buy and
cross-compatibility you know you're free
to use
any part of any of those with any of our
libraries as well i think for the most
part that's been working for people
thank you i would add maybe uh a common
bit that was also uh mentioned on the
chat uh
is the pseudo-random number generation
um
that is something that uh as a first
newcomer to jax might might be a little
bit uh
surprising if you're used to numpy where
you don't have to
reason about the state of the random
number generator almost at all
i would say though that while it can be
surprising at first it actually pays off
in the long run so once you get used to
actually
this way of of dealing with random
number generation
i i think and it is in some sense
at least personally i kind of ended up
with the conclusion that this was
actually the right way all along in some
sense
and that it there is also a very nice um
document in in the jacks documentation
about the
the prng design explaining the reasons
and the motivations
for for the the way jax deals with
random numbers
i think that is a great read i think as
a newcomer
if you're maybe a bit puzzled at the
beginning by random numbers
just read that doc because it will it
will think clarify a lot
yeah i wholeheartedly agree with what
matteo is saying like once you've used
jack's rngs like
all other rngs that maintain their own
stay silent they become very scary all
of a sudden
so definitely
cool so um so we we
are at time um
the thank you all so much for your
questions
i there might be one more slide left uh
is is this correct mateo haha there we
go
cool so so thank you everybody for
coming
um absolutely please make sure to share
your jax projects
um on social media whatever your
favorite flavor of social media
is um github is also social um
and it is my favorite social uh hangout
place
um but anything that you create please
tag it with jack's ecosystem
so that we can make sure to see it and
to share it
and if you're interested in contributing
there are many issues that are good for
first contributors on the jax repo
many places to get involved and we look
forward to seeing
what you create thank you so much
everyone for attending thank you to
jack's core
and for all of the jax ecosystem teams
for presenting your work and for getting
us all very excited
i know i am significantly more excited
somehow than i was even an hour ago
so thank you everybody have a great day
have a great nurips
and see you soon